hey
hey good night
look at this right here look at this
right here
nope nope this is cake from dirty boxing
and you're starting your feet no yeah
back that
here wait here's what you look good yeah
no no
[Music]
pop up
now you know
you know
all right i'm sorry i did do that
don't have shoes on
no you're going through that seatbelt
[ __ ] with me
now
okay
come on man wait give him my date i
don't know your pants
give them the date i'm in i'm going to
tell them
this weekend tonight breaks down comedy
club
ll this weekend next not this weekend
there oh my god
june 3rd to the 5th don't worry about
brendan just come to see
where are you june 10 through the 12th
10th through the 12th all right go see
him you're in
oklahoma with the club
i don't
thank you for doing that i appreciate it
you know i let him
get my dad
[Applause]
you know i started re-watching because
season four is about to drop yellowstone
that's why i'm wearing the hat it's a
good show huh that's not but they don't
wear the hat on you
they do though they wear them rip
where's they wearing that
when you're a barista my boy from daisy
may made it okay so be cool dude
i'm being cool you go to hip-hop videos
in hotel rooms
that kind of that kind of way that kind
of brings my head down
i knew i opened up to you and now you're
using it against me that's [ __ ]
amazing
oh my ted's working oh still wear
whitebeard that's cool
it's not 1980. i can't help it it's a
habit it makes me just
there's nothing wrong with tesla's wow
[Music]
a lot of dough and dirt through water
obstacles cause anything is possible